alexander okay
okay
let me try a different opening i'm
giving away all my
my secrets so far
are people do you hear d3 still
i don't know
i uh played one of my
my better games since um as a kid
against stalmatov with that with this
line
one miniature miniature and
knight f6 is exactly what you're not
supposed to do because
e4 is supposed to be pretty strong but
maybe he
knows something that doesn't i i don't
but really if one f5 is your reporter
against
against knight f3 then d3 really should
be on the top of
your list of moves you're um
you're prepared against so
but i have to admire the the bravado
in which he uh with which he conducts
this game
okay i guess that's
sort of sensible do you have anything
better
i guess i should just take
change queens
oh wait a second i was about to pre-move
my g5 maybe knight e5 is also
okay 95 whatever
[Music]
so i'm thinking king e893
probably should prevent knight d5 by
going c6
and then i guess bishop f4
and uh
i suppose ambition before anyways
it feels like i'm a bit better
unless again 96
these guys really have no no respect
it's a good thing though shouldn't be
scared of me
um let me see okay knight d5
e5 is forced
knight to seven kingdom 7988
ef castles king c8
knight f7
i don't like it so i'm just gonna admit
that hp4 was a poor move
and just play this position
which i'm not too thrilled about
if he didn't have the right to castle
here i would say that
position is absolutely equal but
now i suppose i may have a slight pull
but but not much
and i'm sorry people for the
for the absolute lack of fireworks here
it's just a dull ending
slightly better but it's gonna take a
lot of work
yeah i could go
bishop d4 followed by knight b5 but that
is
that sort of pawn hunting is not my
style so
i might do it next unless he plays kf7
obviously then i have to do something
else
but what
just protecting c2
in order to to move my knight away from
e4 at some points
but now
he's doing all right protecting the
the g5 square
which is very sensible
trying to re reroute my my knights now i
want to go
knight c to e4 and
and later knight d3
and if it goes bishop b4 now i'm
kind of hoping that knight d3 is not bad
with the idea of bishop c3 then knight
to e5
so he went for
this option which is very sensible but
now
now i'm a little bit better
not much though
yeah this guy is playing really well
i guess i can go rookie to d1
just trying to to get my knight
somewhere he cannot go rook d8 because i
i take and i think 95 followed by
i'm not too unhappy to see this exchange
and a5
root b3 maybe b6 then i have
and i can move the rook again
i still don't have much
it's gonna be a long game still folks
so we're hoping to tempt him to go to
the to the rook ending
i feel like there there might have some
chances
yes now i have to activate the rook
yeah he's playing well he's not allowing
rook
c4 at least not immediately
because then i would have had the chance
to hint that
at age 4 later on
that's pretty much
it's going to c5 now
suppose i should go c3
if not b3 then i go h4
might have some initiative
so he's gonna run out of time but it was
a really tough game
and uh what can i say
he played really well for for his rating
that's there's no doubt about that